schau mal um das ist das neue
skandalbuch feuchtgebiete
da geht es richtig zur sache da und ob
das den sachen die kann ich gar nicht
aussprechen weg richtig eklig oder bei
uns an der uni reden alle nur noch über
dieses buch ab dies hätte bei uns nicht
gegeben
das glaube ich dir gerne nein das mir so
verklemmt gewesen werden dass wir so es
auch andere flüchten müssen
bei uns zugegangen ist mir haben wir
keinen fernseher gehabt also haben wir
die sau raus gelassen wir haben sie
abgetrieben gefilden die caligula
erweisen glaube gegen uns und zokora
diesmal und besserungsanstalten gegen
dieses bei uns an der schule zugegangen
ist
die pid ist so ein gramm nach gebiet
tätig bei uns müssen wie ich weiß gar
nicht hören aber auch der kunst aber
noch was lernen medien
ich erzählte die oberarme wie sie damals
mit der kompletten fußball mannschaft
vom fc 1 1 beim zelten war
[Applaus]
da kann ich nur sagen armes vater omas
bester bringt die gute alte zeit zurück
da stetigen franzi thyssenkrupp
vorzustellen
[Applaus]
der rhein ist das chance fragen
littering meine war so schüchtern jugend
direkt auf hefe müssen 100 fotos hat er
war doch der wahre liebe
warum nicht zu bringen